we know that the executive branch of the
government essentially had their boot on
the neck of these people at Twitter
[Music]
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator today I'm in New York speaking
with David zweig musician author
novelist
lecturer but crucially for this
interview
one of the journalists behind the
Twitter files and uh well David thank
you so much for spending spending the uh
uh this next hour or so with me uh
discussing all these things glad to be
here
um uh so uh I want to get into the
Twitter files and at the moment
it's being debated in Congress as I
understand with the the house oversight
and accountability committee and
specifically some of your work has been
debated or
looked into we'll get into that and the
significance of that and I'm curious to
ask about the the Twitter files
experience itself but before all of that
I think it's worth understanding why you
were invited and it's I think it's
because of your uh reporting through
covid so there are a few issues through
covid that um that made you sort of a
heterodox journalist really I was
wondering if you could tell me a little
bit about some of those uh topics sure
yeah
um
well the Twitter files are happening
Matt taibi was
um you know had put out at least one or
a few and then I saw that Barry Weiss um
was also invited to you know to go to um
to go to Twitter and report and you know
and she now has kind of a media Empire
so it's not just Barry but it's you know
variety of journals who work for or with
her and um so I knew Barry and some
editors who knew her and I and I emailed
them and said hey you know
um I noticed you guys have access to the
Twitter files I just want to suggest a
few things it you know and I was very
sheepish I almost felt apologetic I was
like just in case um you want to look
into X Y or Z related to covet here's
what I would do I would look into this
you know 10 minutes later I get a
response can you drop everything and get
on a flight to San Francisco I said okay
so um it was so and you know and they
asked me to come out I think I am
considered one one of the few
journalists if not the only one who is
really done a tremendous amount of
investigative reporting related to
the underlying science
um that that has been used to justify a
lot of pandemic policies and I've done
so I should say there are plenty of
journalists doing that I think I'm
considered one of the only ones or the
only one who's done so at a lot of what
are considered sort of mainstream and
Legacy
um Publications like New York Magazine
the Atlantic
um even at a piece in the New York Times
early on during the pandemic so um so I
think because of that
um
work that I had been doing for several
years at that point
um and and because I knew Barry I had
written for for her earlier they brought
me out to they're like you're the guy we
want to be looking into covid what what
if in those mainstream uh Publications
took your work on when when they didn't
take many sort of counter-narrative uh
reports on yeah it's a really good
question
um well I've been writing for a lot of
them for years so I already knew um
editors
um at a variety of Publications but the
interesting thing is I mean they I've
always been a freelancer
um so you know and as an independent
journalist it's it's a totally different
thing than they have you know all these
places have large staff halfs of Staff
writers so
there's a couple interesting threads
there which one is why weren't any of
the staff members writing from the same
perspective that I was writing from and
then as a separate issue
um I've been very fortunate that there's
been at least a small number of editors
who I know who are sympathetic to what I
was saying that I like everyone I make
mistakes but I try to be incredibly
meticulous and thorough with my
reporting and
um my editor Daniel engberg who I'd work
with at wired and now he's at the
Atlantic for example Jebediah Reed at
New York and some others you know when I
pitched them something very early on in
the beginning I try to lay out a case
where it's inarguable you know at least
in my mind where I'm like here's what
I'd like to write about the schools are
closed in America the entire country
this has never happened before they are
opening throughout Europe This was at
the end of April beginning of May why
and no one else as far as I could see
was writing it I was at work
um on a book at the time about a totally
different topic because of course the
pandemic had just started so I wouldn't
be writing about that I was writing a
non-fiction book I was under contract
and I found myself completely unable to
concentrate on the book because what was
happening around me seemed slightly
crazy and my sort of my default is to
always go to the source I spent many
years as a fact Checker and magazines
um and now fact checking is this sort of
like politicized activity but back then
um the job was just for nerds like me
who just wanted to and enjoyed the
process of poking holes and things you
read someone spends all this time
writing this beautiful article in the
editor edits and you get to go in and
rip it rip it apart and be like is this
true and the main thing that I learned
in that training is you can't just take
if something the backup the source for a
statement shouldn't be or cannot simply
be the New York Times or some other
publication you have to go to the source
and in in some sense you're never done
fact checking you're just you can always
go one layer deeper even if you speak to
the person who made some statement you
then have to find out well is it true
what they said you know and then so that
partly that's my brain the way I work
I'm always seeing the sort of errors and
things and partly it's through that sort
of training of doing that work all the
time those two things together
my mindset is I'm always curious and
wondering well is this true what they're
telling me David shouldn't isn't that
shouldn't that be normal shouldn't all
generally speaking well I mean well
here's the thing and this is a big part
of the book that I'm writing now about
um American schools during the pandemic
um is that one of the things you saw or
over and over in all sorts of
Publications and in you know TV news and
everywhere else is time and again that
um they would quote experts saying
whatever you know the experts say x y or
Z or they would interview a few people
an infectious disease person whatever
saying you know X Y or Z opinion about
something but they didn't but the
Articles weren't actually what is the
underlying evidence for that just
because this person is telling me this
that doesn't mean it's true and that
goes back to that fact-checking brain I
have in this mindset where I'm always a
little bit skeptical of everything that
people are telling me and so in the
beginning we were told all these things
and they made intuitive sense there is a
virus that's happening I was very
frightened I wanted my kids home you
know we all tried to
stay you know somewhat isolated from
other people but very early on we knew
the data out of China was very clear and
then the data that started coming out of
Europe was very clear that children were
at extraordinarily low risk so we knew
this there was no ambiguity about it and
there were and and more broadly the age
gradient of risk it was clear from early
on what was happening
um and nevertheless the schools were
closed and then it got even worse where
the schools were opening in places and
they remained closed in America and the
reason given if a reason was given at
all was well that's Europe that's
different than here and I asked why yeah
why is it different what does that mean
exactly and basically what I've been
doing now for the past couple years
aside from my reporting In Articles is
in writing this book I just keep asking
why and digging deeper and deeper and
really I think all this is about
empiricism it's about
is this thing that you're told Can You
observe it yourself and if you can't
observe it yourself is there something
concrete that actually underlies what
they're telling you
um so to me that that's kind of what it
comes down to it's like what is the
empirical evidence actually telling us
so if it wasn't empirical evidence that
they were making their decisions based
off of what was the why why were they
keeping the schools closed here in
America well that's that's a very I have
uh probably like a thousand page book
that's going to answer that question
what is the why but I mean I think in
the broad Strokes it has to do with
um you know what they would call and
philosophy is called an appeal to
Authority which is
um like I was talking about a moment ago
experts were saying this and that's
sufficient when the expert says this and
there this there's this sort of
astonishing lack of curiosity I think
from a lot of journalists I don't blame
regular people for for saying the CDC is
telling me blah blah blah okay most
people they have jobs they're dealing
with their kids they're doing whatever
that's not their obligation necessarily
I'd like for regular people to be more
curious but I appreciate why that's but
for someone like me that's my obligation
to dig into it and certainly more so
than me I'm just an independent
journalist this wasn't even my beat
necessarily I don't understand this sort
of what it what in my view was this
incredible lack of curiosity from people
where this was their job this was their
beat to dig into this stuff and you know
one of the things that I often think
about and then I'm writing about in my
book is that
um you know liberals in general of which
I think I still am a liberal and count
my have counted myself as for for many
years my adult life and and liberals and
also journalists
um have always had like a really strong
degree of skepticism toward large
institutions the government the military
big business religion these large
institutions of society yet somehow in
my view that skepticism
vaporized when it came to the pandemic
and what the public health authorities
were telling us well it did here in New
York but there's other parts of the
country where in fact no the the
tradition of of questioning government
or big government true very much
maintained and actually we saw it split
pretty much along political lines it did
and then that created you know the
circumstance that I feel like you've
found yourself in as well and you know
why why you and I are talking which is
that if you were politically just and I
don't by the way I don't think of myself
as left or right politically I have a
diverse range of views on a wide range
of complicated topics nevertheless I've
aligned myself as a Democrat and as a
liberal for most of my adult life and
for people like me or if I can include
you in this of course to that there was
this sort of like you know hard line
drawn and you couldn't step over that
line yeah and so what's been fascinating
is from the very beginning when the
first piece I published in like the
first week of May of 2020 through until
now but but particularly in the
beginning that I would get I mean almost
every day I get emails or messages from
people saying hey you know I'm like you
I I'm a liberal or I voted you know that
oftentimes it's very funny but in the
beginning in particular
anytime I would speak with um you know
an infectious disease doctor or or some
other person in public health or even
regular people nine out of ten times the
conversation would start with this
Preamble that the person I need to let
you know I voted for Obama and and I you
know I hate Trump and I've been a
liberal but and then dot dot dot and
like and that's how what a remarkable
commentary on our culture and on the
left what a commentary that is about
what the modern left is today that
people including like highly
credentialed very doctors who work at
very prestigious you know medical
schools in the country and and abroad
that people felt the need to have this
sort of like apologia you know before
this this preemptive kind of throat
clearing before we could then get down
to business and talk
um that is diminished automatically over
the last three years but it still exists
to some extent now
um and and I think it's like a really
remarkable commentary the fact that
people feel that I don't know if you if
you sort of feel like I'm guilty of it I
do it right for me I you know I was
brought up canvassing for the liberal
Democrat Party in the UK which is
basically a Centrist party and very much
come from a liberal background and get
all sorts of attacks in fact only this
week you've we were called by Senator
Scott weiner in California uh one of
Elon musk's right-wing conspiracy
propaganda machine Stooges or something
like that exactly it's an example of it
and then I've had equivalent stuff it's
it's so you say it's diminished over the
last three years I I'm not fully
convinced it as diminished well and the
interesting thing is
um I I replied to him because you know
when you have a very high level
politician calling you out you know on a
platform like Twitter yeah it probably
behooves you to reply sometimes and I
said yeah and remember but verbatim but
I essentially wrote back to him I said
you know hey thanks Senator
um what exactly in my reporting is right
wing what exactly am I reporting was
misleading or false to say that I'm part
of a propaganda machine and you know
what his response was was he didn't
respond yeah of course you know so it's
just so
the environment still exists that guy
obviously has a motive to to to Brand
anyone that's against sort of what he
perceives to be the appropriate thing as
the bad people and that's to spin this
whole dynamic you know in covid and then
obviously a variety of other
you know cultural areas anytime you
question something you're automatically
on the wrong team yeah you know so I've
noticed that by the way it's not just
the the left or Progressive Democrats
the conservatives do it just as much
right you're right I think I'm so they
certainly do it anyway I think I'm more
sensitive and more aware of the left
doing it only because that felt like my
tribe for my adult life so you're right
and you're right to point out that that
you know the conservatives and right
they are just as tribal in in their own
thing and you know people can't
um you know can't be disloyal to them
either
um I think just I I felt ascent and
still do feel a sense of of and of
betrayal almost like an astonishment so
I had this moment
um I wrote a piece um for the Atlantic
about a masking study in schools in
Arizona that was published by by the CDC
in their journal mmwr and the study I
won't get into the boring granular
details but the study was just
terminally flawed there it wasn't just
oh there's problems with the methodology
there were factual errors in the study
and I did an extensive investigation
into this because this was important
this was being used to justify policy
um and you can't do that when there are
errors and I was emailing back and forth
with the authors of the study as well as
the editors at the cdc's journal I said
look there are errors here this is what
they are I'm getting in from this isn't
my opinion this is I'm getting
information from the state of Arizona
from the county health departments they
are giving me data that's different from
what you have in your study are you
telling me that the State of Arizona is
wrong you know with the like that and I
wrote with them I wrote to them and said
in the CDC to the CDC and to the editors
of the of the journal put out by and the
authors of the study I said you know
this is the information I have from the
state
um it's different from what you have in
the study
and they wrote back to me and said there
are no errors
and it was this
moment where something like broke in my
head I had already been reporting on
science and covert related matters you
know throughout the pandemic
but it was this moment where
I couldn't believe that
a health authority I imagine somewhere
like the CIA or or some other you know
or some big Corporation or something
they have invested interests in in kind
of you know lying or at least
snowballing certain things
but I couldn't believe what happened
that I'm like but these people know that
this is untrue they know this is not
true
um what's in this study and that night I
was like kind of like crawled in a ball
like and and I had this like incredible
migraine and my wife was talking to me
and I was like almost on the verge of
tears it's embarrassing to admit but it
was just this moment this sense of of
like
betrayal and almost this like I couldn't
believe that I was this naive before but
I never expected people within Public
Health to actually behave in this manner
well the implication if you if you think
that they knew is that it's not
incompetence actually it's ideology
do you think that's fair so I think
about this all the time you know in
relation to that specific incident but
more broadly you know a lot of the
things that Rochelle wallenski the head
of the CDC says are incorrect they're
just they're just false or or at best
one could say misleading and and I talk
with
um people who are in the public health
field I'm friends with I yeah I would
say I'm friendly you know I'm friends
with now I'm in these text groups with
various infectious disease doctors that
you know ivy league medical schools and
with immunologists at top hospitals so
I'm in these text groups with these
people we chat every day and we are
always talking about I always ask them
like she knows right you know or someone
else or fauci knows this right and we're
always trying to figure out whether it
is and and is this on purpose or is it
incompetence or is it something else and
I think that it's this weird mix of all
of them together here where I you know
human beings have motivated reasoning
and for a variety of reasons they want
and need to believe certain things to be
true and when you want and need
something to be true
you are able of convincing yourself of
All Sorts you know it's it's
confirmation bias um this is often
referred to when you're looking at data
or evidence you are you have a bias
toward confirming what you already
believe
um and there's some research on this
that the smarter someone is the more
susceptible they are to this because
when you're really bright and you are in
a particular field you have the ability
to rationalize all any way you want yeah
so that's my working theory is that I
think most these people in their minds
are not purposefully saying something
that's untrue although I think some of
them are somehow if you're in a position
in politics and you make policy based on
certain things and you're you're kind of
career is almost tied up in in being
right so you have to be right right and
push it for your own sake I try to be
generous though and say that at least
for most of them most of the time I
think there's some sort of very very
very profound motivated reasoning and
that when you're intelligent you are
able to rationalize all sorts of things
yeah
um and I think that's what we've
observed over and over yeah
um and I think that ties into what I was
saying before about you know empiricism
and like you can believe something but
if the evidence is showing you something
else or if there is a lack of evidence
behind what you believe that matters and
that's the thing I picked up on with
masks I mean I don't have a particular
interest in masks it's nothing I've been
but the evidence base behind Community
masking as an effective mitigation
measure is at best mixed and Incredibly
weak and that is from the CDC itself
that is from the Cochrane review out of
um out of Britain which is considered
the you know the eminent
organization that does these um
systematic reviews of randomized control
trials prior to the pandemic they said
this is what the all the aggregate of
evidence said this this particular thing
people wearing masks in a community
setting it's just not particularly
effective and
so it's a remarkable moment when you
have
um the government and you know people
like Anthony Fouch and these other
people telling you all of a sudden
magically that this is going to work
when none of the evidence supported that
it doesn't mean that it doesn't work but
it means we lacked evidence to to say
and they spoke with such certainty and
you were a piece of garbage if you
question this only the hassle
Republicans and the bad people
um weren't wearing masks or even were
questioning whether this was a good idea
but yet that's exactly what what the
evidence base pointed toward was this is
not necessarily an effective
um uh measure at the community level I
actually remember being here in New York
at it during the
pandemic I can't remember exactly when
and walking down the street in the
middle of the street without a mask and
being hissed at hissed
by someone else who was about four
meters away from there's no danger there
was a kind of something was uh really
wrong there but there was another uh
topic which which has reared its head
again which you I think very early on
it's myocarditis and the empiricism
around that and and I think it was as
early as December 2020 you were writing
about that and and the data particularly
on teenagers that actually it was a wash
uh uh in in terms of taking the vaccine
and and the uh the the the likelihood of
actually getting you know preventing
infection versus you getting myocarditis
do we
do you feel now with with the stories
about excess deaths that you have
indicated in that or do you feel sort of
um any disappointment about how that
information was received you're
reporting well
um
yes I I've been on this from the
beginning
um I interviewed the Israeli scientist
who put out the initial report that kind
of really made it in the news
um where they found a raid of between
one and three thousand or one in six
thousand for young males um who are who
are getting vaccinated so this was the
initial thing I was due to texting with
this guy in Israel trying to I don't
even know how I was able to connect with
him but it was it was an amazing moment
and
um so I've been following it very
closely and have written a handful of
pieces since then
um I will say this regarding the the the
deaths and stuff now which is
we don't know
um again this gets back to that there is
because there weren't properly done
randomized trials
um with of sufficient power which means
generally like with enough people
for young people the pool is already
mixed at this point almost everyone has
already had covid and then you know an
incredibly High number of people have
been vaccinated so I think it is wrong
to automatically point to the vaccine
um people do that and say oh it's the
vaccine you know um and conversely it's
also wrong with the other side where
people say it's from covid that this is
happening
um and even on top of that even the
numbers themselves as far as what is
excess death those are extrapolations
um when we talk about excess death
numbers we don't really know because
it's it's made and they're made using by
modeling where scientists look at well
how many people die each year normally
and then they model what's going to
happen you know what should happen the
next year but they have to account for a
difference in population you know it's a
it's a projection it's not an exact
thing so you have all these different
moving pieces from everyone being
vaccinated everyone having covid the the
numbers themselves are an extrapolation
so I think people need to be very
careful about out speaking with
certainty in whatever Direction related
to that that doesn't mean that it's
definitively not uh you know related to
vaccine in some cases
um and there's a lot of evidence I think
that suggests that is the case
um there's this incredible study out of
Germany where they
um where they were looking at um
cadavers and they this I forget what the
number I think it was four out of 16 or
4 out of 20 they found
um this sort of myocardial
um uh damage in the hearts in young
people and it was immediately after
vaccination so until unless you're doing
that type of analysis it's very hard to
know um definitively one way or the
other but they're but that study in a
variety of others certainly are are
suggestive that something's going on I
won't get into you sound a little bit on
the fence on the on the issue but I'm
not on the fence regarding this I the
excess death thing is is too complicated
in my view for the reasons I just
mentioned but what I'm not on the fence
about is the evidence is very clear
dating back to this initial Israeli um
study that came out that
young people and in Far and Away young
men
um roughly between like age 16 and 24
but but you know but it tapers off after
that are at an elevated risk for
myocarditis um following an mRNA vaccine
there's no ambiguity about that the CDC
would readily admit I mean you can look
at the slides um that are shown in the
cdc's um in their advisory committee uh
meetings and in the FDA uh meetings as
well so there's no ambiguity about that
um what they claim is that despite that
risk it is still worth it
um for a young person to get vaccinated
there are a number and I think an
increasing number of Highly credentialed
uh people in the field who would be who
would disagree with that who would say
you know and there was a study that just
came out recently but there have been
many that yet another study that found
once you've been infected you have a
very robust
um immune protection against the next
you know exposure to the virus getting
infected that doesn't mean that it was a
bad idea for elderly people and people
at risk to get vaccinated in the
beginning in fact it was probably a very
good idea um you want the first time
you're exposed to the virus to be a time
where it's where it's a relatively
controlled experience through a
vaccination
um but almost every young person has
already had covid and the no there's as
far as I'm aware there is no evidence as
of today that getting an additional
vaccine dose after you've already been
infected has any sort of meaningful
difference in reducing
um the the incidence of severe disease
that it's just that is what the evidence
shows and there's study after study in
places like the New England Journal of
Medicine and elsewhere that support that
and you know in places like Britain and
elsewhere in Europe their vaccine
policies are very different from what
they are in the U us
the fascinating thing and all you know
our whole conversation in my mind it all
ties together whether it's with school
closures whether it's with masking
whether it's with vaccines the U.S
um among sort of like Western Nations I
think has been uniquely aggressive in
their approach to most of these things
we're the only country that masked
two-year-olds there is no
randomized trial evidence
that shows that this is beneficial for a
two-year-old you know what what is the
what is the reduction in absolute
numbers of incidents of severe disease
for a two-year-old from wearing a mask
they have no clue and that's why the
World Health Organization says we don't
want little kids at that age wearing
Mass the ecdc that's the European
version of the CDC
um they said we don't want kids in
Primary School wearing masks at all but
the United States if you were to say I'm
not so sure this is a good idea for my
six-year-old to be wearing a mask again
you are some right-wing lunatic jerk
um or you know as I was referred to by
that guy you were talking about before
that that politician that to even
question this stuff there's this
fairly kind of like it's this amazing I
think this American sort of like
centrism that this inability to see
what's happening elsewhere and I'm like
as far as I'm aware the kids in Europe
are not all dead because they weren't
wearing masks there's no evidence that
they were at any greater risk than the
kids in America
um so you know and so from that to the
vaccine policies where you know
universities in in America many of the
most elite universities have the most
aggressive vaccine requirements for
their students imagine you're a healthy
19 year old man maybe you've already had
one or two doses of the vaccine you've
already had covid once maybe even twice
you've spoken to your doctor you're
aware of that evidence and you're saying
I don't think I need yet another
vaccination and you attend some Elite
University and they say either you get
another dose of this vaccine or you're
out
I mean and and that is such it's so
harmful and so fascinating to me and
troubling that we've come to this place
um and that so I wrote a piece about
this recently
um where there's an organization called
fire um it's an acronym but where they
made a list of something like 200
universities in America and they rank
them based on their um free speech
environment I think they interviewed
something like 40 000 students uh virus
civil liberties group correct yeah okay
I forget precisely what the letters
stand for but they they did this survey
they've done it for a few years now
where they made a list and
and um and when I saw that list in the
back of my head and I just glanced it I
said you know I'm I'm kind of seeing a
correlation between the universities
that are more open to free speech and a
free exchange of ideas and you see a
correlation between them and what I
suspect might be their policies toward
vaccines so I looked into it and
even the amount that I thought might
exist I was blown away it was one to one
that the top five schools for the most
um you know the best free speech
environments no vaccine requirement at
all they all strongly encouraged it but
it wasn't required the bottom five all
required multiple vaccinations the
bottom two Columbia University
um I think it was um Penn both required
the bivalent booster or you're out and
but so you have the bottom the worst
universities for free speech in the
country also have the most aggressive
vaccination policy the best ones for and
and it's just remarkable how you can see
that and almost all of the ivy league
universities are in are in the bottom
the bottom like uh 20 for free speech
according to that thing and also have
the same you know these same types of
vaccine policies isn't that amazing it's
that's sort of the the these large
themes I feel like we can't escape them
there's something about as you and I as
people who generally have been have been
or still are liberal
observing the kind of ill liberalism of
of the left yeah um so it's a
correlation so the the other the
universities you didn't name any of the
universities that are more pro-free
speech and more Pro you use the term
bodily autonomy right yes which and it's
interesting which is an interesting
choice of well words to use there I
because a good friend of mine
um very far left guy very smart he's in
in DC politics except
um he wrote to me and he was very upset
that I used that term and I and I admit
I actually didn't think about it very
long
um I just threw it in there because
obviously that's a very
um emotionally triggering phrase related
to Reproductive Rights for women and
obviously that's different from being
vaccinated but I wrote back to him and I
said look you know I hear you maybe I
shouldn't have used that that term I
don't know
um just because of the largest it wasn't
intentionally provocative no it wasn't
just because you eat it what could be
more of an infringement on bodily
autonomy than forcing a medical product
to be injected into a young person that
they don't want and that we know has
zero or close to zero epidemiological
benefit at this point it doesn't stop
infection or transmission it may
temporarily there's a very ephemeral
benefit of reducing the chance of
getting infected but it's it vaporizes
relatively quickly and if someone
already had covid their protection is
just as robust if not more so this
there's not a strong scientific basis to
justify forcing someone so to me bodily
autonomy even if that is a very loaded
term certainly in a technical sense was
very appropriate do you think you'd find
a correlation if you also added
pro-life versus pro-choice into your
metric so it wasn't just free speech
vaccine I mean one would think yeah and
I am I am
as far pro-choice as someone can be I'm
I
but to me that aligns very much with
also being pro-choice quote-unquote for
not being forced to be vaccinated for a
vaccine that what they would call is
non-sterilizing it does not prevent
infection I think getting vaccinated is
a good idea if you haven't been exposed
to covid and you want to reduce the
likelihood of having a serious reaction
to it but that's your own decision in
the same way that I don't go bungee
jumping because that but someone else
might want to do that that's different
from a social justification of you need
to do this to protect others you're
selling awfully like a right-wing
program
[Laughter]
um but so before getting into the uh to
defiles experience I think one of the
other things that uh I I maybe in the
eyes of the other journalists on that
project qualified you for it was your
participation in the Great Barrington
declaration launch and the last guests I
had on the show was Jay battacharya one
of the co-authors so can you tell me a
little bit about that experience
yeah it's it's um it's interesting that
is now both my sort of badge of honor
and also and then to other people that
is the mark of the beast you know that's
you know multiple hit pieces written
against me and people still tweet you
know as a non-sequitur but I might you
know tweet one thing and they say you
were at the Great Barrington in
declaration that that's you know I'm
automatically the villain for being
there the funny thing is I didn't even
know there was such a thing there there
would be a declaration I was invited by
Martin caldorf to come out he said Dave
you know myself Jay bhattacharya Sinatra
Gupta
um and um Stefan baral who who joined in
uh remotely
um he's at Johns Hopkins he said you
know why don't you come and you know
interview us and and we want to present
our side our case you know for what we
think is an appropriate response to the
pandemic well as did he tell you it was
going to be advocating against lockdowns
necessarily use that terminology I had
interviewed Martin for an article that I
wrote about um in the states I don't
think this is very popular in England or
throughout Europe but they had this
hybrid learning model where like you're
in for two days a week out for two days
a week at the schools because they
wanted them to be less crowded and I
interviewed Martin about that because
there was a fair amount of evidence that
that actually was going to increase the
the um likelihood of transmission
because while the kids weren't in school
an assumption was being made that
they're just locked in their home and
while some kids were
um many other kids particularly from
underprivileged families where do you
think they went they went to a daycare
they went to some an elderly person's
home who needed to take to take care of
them so they were being exposed to tons
of kids who weren't even in their their
bubble of their school potentially if
you're into these other environments so
Martin and a few other people I had
interviewed for the article said this
they've got this all wrong this idea of
this hybrid schooling that this is going
to make everyone safer not only do we
not have evidence that it makes people
safer in fact it may even be worse so
anyway so I interviewed him for that so
already this was the contrarian you know
kind of idea I don't know if we
specifically talked about you know
so-called lockdowns but I knew he had
um a different perspective on what the
CDC and Anthony fauci and the government
were telling us needed to be done with
school closures and a variety of other
things so I knew this was going to be an
event where I'm exposed to sort of you
know I forget I think like in the
military where they have like the red
team they use they have the sort of like
the alternative
um view is it it was being proposed and
as a journalist I mean I was like I'm
there of course like this this I had the
opportunity to interview these
scientists from Stanford Harvard I'm in
Oxford I think she's at Oxford yeah um
wow this is amazing so um it was only
after the fact after I had interviewed
them that I found out they were putting
together this this you know formal
declaration
um so
I guess the interesting thing is I was
there because this seemed interesting to
me because I just wanted to be open to
learning more um and and I think
Martin and Jay had tried to get some
some more journalists who are far more
prominent than I am at you know sort of
the more you know Legacy Publications
and I think they they weren't interested
um I'm interested I mean I'll talk to
anyone
um so I went and that's what I've been
doing from day one is I will talk to
anyone what and I'm always interested in
hearing well what is the quote other
side what is there it doesn't mean a
false equivalency it means if there's
Not Strong evidence for what's happening
then we need to talk about this yeah and
try to think about what is the broader
picture of what's going on well
particularly if you'd you were seeing
the the like you described earlier the
CDC avoiding the evidence against the
empirical truth and and there's this
look if you are if a doctor has a bias
toward an intervention if you're a
surgeon you want to operate if you are
this is you know a natural thing they
want and people who work in public
health have a bias and it comes from a
good place they want to be useful there
can you imagine Anthony fauci saying um
look we are being presented with this
you know horrible situation I have to be
honest with you the American people we
don't have a lot of strong evidence
about some of these measures but I try
wearing a mask we'll see what will
happen but we're not certain you know we
have to if he was honest with people if
they said we're not sure about what
happens if you close schools for this
duration of time I think it would have
been a very different conversation I
think for the first lockdown I think
that's pretty much people accept that it
was worth we didn't really fully
understand what's going on it was worth
taking extra precaution so there's sort
of two things going on here that we're
talking about one of them is the
effectiveness of these various things
Mass lockdowns vaccines
and the other side is what are the what
are the harms of these things so what
was missing and I know this is what Jay
and Martin you know were so concerned
about
um what is what was largely missing from
the conversation was well what are the
downsides what are the harms and what
for the FDA to approve a drug or some
sort of medical intervention typically
you have to show safety and
Effectiveness
um and safety would incorporate well
what are the harms of this thing and you
have to weigh everything out
um they didn't do that with these
mitigations and understandably in you
know March the beginning or middle of
March there still is a fair amount of
confusion okay we're not sure what's
going to happen the safest thing to do
let's all take a moment everyone stay
home
that makes sense that seems to I think
in retrospect that wasn't necessarily
correct in in all but a very few places
perhaps you know including New York City
um where there actually was an explosion
of cases but
um put setting that you know setting
that aside the retrospective look that
it probably wasn't even appropriate
doing that it was reasonable even if not
appropriate I think where it became
unreasonable was as the weeks and months
kept wearing on and then the burden of
proof shifts and there was a lack of
awareness of the harms being done you
have kids around America we're talking
about 50 or 60 million kids who are
healthy who were forced to stay home
that is an extraordinary moment that
happened
um and that continued to happen kids in
California many of them in pockets of
Virginia and elsewhere did not set foot
in a school building for a year and some
of these kids and it wasn't just the
schools it was everything that went with
it the play dates with friends you were
if you did that you were crazy or some
right-wing lunatic it the arts program
Athletics I spoke to
um this guy who was running a youth
football program
in New York and just the stories of
these kids this was their ticket out
their ticket out of out of a bad
situation they were growing up in and it
was taken away from them like that that
so these if you are a healthy kid and
you you knew that the coronavirus it's
not zero it's not that there was Zero
risk but the risk was on par with any
number of other risks that we face every
day from getting in a car to you know
um something like 700 something kids
drown every year
um but we still go swimming because
that's part of life when we get on the
highway there's a reason why the speed
limit is not 35 miles an hour we accept
some degree of risk in society for the
benefits of doing different things
and that that risk calculation was
thrown out the window I believe in my
view and what I will argue extensively
um in my book on the topic is that when
you think about that you know 16 year
old kid who was healthy who is that
extraordinarily low risk of this virus
and his life was essentially destroyed
um by what happened that matters
absolutely
um uh so
take me to on your journey to San
Francisco you get the call from Barry
you're here in New York Upstate and you
you fly over at the drop of a hat right
snap of a finger you arrive you go
downtown San Francisco Twitter HQ what's
the atmosphere what's going on well the
first thing I noticed and boy I'm gonna
if I didn't sound like a right-wing
person before
um everyone hold your back
um San Francisco at least the part where
Twitter is located is just abysmal I
mean I I because I'm a New Yorker I
always walk everywhere
um and so the hotel I was at was about a
mile I think from Twitter and in my mind
it's inconceivable to me when I go
somewhere I always like to walk no
matter where so it's inconceivable me
that I would take
um an Uber or something like that to get
from a mile I'm gonna walk
um and as I walk down it was just I mean
there were literally people smoking meth
on the street in front of me it's just a
bombed out pit at least that part of the
city yeah um Mission District I think
that's what it is yeah it's like Market
Street or something down there so it was
it was so strange I mean it's far far
worse than New York I mean it's like a
totally different I was there in
November uh staying in a hotel near
Union Square and I saw someone take a
in the middle of the street oh I
mean
for a longer duration I I would have
switched hotel or done something where
it was like walking a gauntlet
um I don't really understand the
Dynamics of how the police work there or
what happened but I mean you can't walk
down at least that main thoroughfare
without walking through people lit like
freebasing meth in front of you so that
was that was the yeah that was the
initiation but I burst through and um
and uh yeah I mean there was it was
funny I mean this was all done
um I think what people some people don't
realize about their Twitter files
because I've seen lots of complaints why
didn't you do this so why didn't you do
that this was like kind of but I think
Michael schellenberger called um he was
one of the the journalists there I mean
I think he called it a smash and grab I
mean this was like fairy spur of the
moment Barry is not the New York Times
she's she's starting this kind of media
Empire but she's still you know a small
thing so this was all just being done in
the moment I think like at 10 o'clock
the night before I was supposed to go in
I'm texting Barry hey um how do I get in
how did that she's like oh let me let me
text the security people so I had to get
through multiple layers of security this
whole thing you know um and eventually I
get in there and myself Michael
schellenberger Lee Fong who's a
journalist and Leighton Woodhouse
um the four of us were there I was there
for three days some of them that those
guys all live in the Bay Area I think so
they they were there
um longer either before and or half
after but I was there with the three of
them and we were in a room
um with the shades were drawn the door
was to remain closed at all times
um and um
you know this was this is a very very
touchy
um operation for multiple reasons not
the least of which was um I think there
was a lot of legal implications about
what was happening so there was an
engineer who was assigned to us who sat
at a laptop in the room and he conducted
um searches for us looking at
um basically anyone any profile of any
person we wanted to look at we could
tell him and I'm looking over her
shoulder he's you know typing it in
looking them up and um and you could see
um whether there are different sort of
like flags on there on their account
um and and so while I was there I knew
just from reporting on this for for the
past several years I knew of so many
instances
um of legitimate correct information
that was nevertheless suppressed in one
way or another
um so I wanted to go there to sort of
like reverse engineer I wanted to
deconstruct and understand how did this
happen
um so that was my mission when I was
there which I think perhaps was slightly
different from what some of the other
reporters were doing there but I wanted
to deconstruct how and why
um if I could get to the Y but at least
the how of of this these types of tweets
and information how is it suppressed and
how did this happen because we all had
an inkling about it that's pretty much
news right and then what was so exciting
is when this stuff came out the Twitter
files was like oh yeah I see I'm not
crazy so did you find out the how
so so the way I view it is they're sort
of were several things happening at once
which is
um at the top there's people making
decisions and some accounts were um were
suppressed or people were even suspended
because Executives at Twitter made that
choice there also is something happening
where there were
um these Bots that they created you know
it's sort of almost through like an AI
or machine learning process where they
kind of and I'm going to use the wrong
term I'm sure for the tech people but
they were essentially crawling you know
and searching throughout the the
platform to see if there are any tweets
that triggered these Bots to to flag
them the boats were trained to
it's an algorithm essentially that was
trained to look for specific type of
content and then the last thing so
there's these three areas you have
people you have Bots and then you have
um these sort of independent contractors
in places like the Philippines who were
deciding who are looking at the stuff
and and I explained in my reporting
um how each of these things worked but
in the end it all comes back to people
because people decide how those Bots are
supposed to function and people decide
these Executives at Twitter decide how
some guy sitting in a cube Farm halfway
across the world and they were given
these decision trees that they get a a
tweet I guess that for one reason or
another maybe a bot Flags the tweet and
then it goes to the contractor sitting
in a cube who then is looking at this
tweet and they go through a decision
tree does it say this yes or no and then
depending on that and it takes you
through you know where how they were
supposed to get to their ultimate
decision and what I try to to articulate
in my reporting on this was there is no
way that a guy sitting at a desk in the
Philippines is going to be able to
adjudicate the accuracy or the
legitimacy of a tweet by a doctor about
myocarditis that's just not happening so
you ended up with this situation where
you had
um people with legitimate content Martin
Cold War if I I cited one of his tweets
um that I highlighted in there
where it was flagged as misleading and
this is a guy who is an expert from
Harvard University who
um who is stating his opinion about and
and nevertheless it was flagged as
misleading and I had multiple instances
of Physicians and even regular people
who were quoting
um quoting from peer-reviewed journals
um they were quoting actual now someone
could quibble about maybe the journal
itself you know this wasn't a well done
study it doesn't matter this is stuff
from accredited journals and those were
labeled as misleading they were um some
of these accounts were suspended there
was a woman who um not a doctor a
regular citizen who was quoting data
from the CDC her tweet got flagged so I
deconstructed about how this happened
through the Bots through the independent
contractors and then ultimately through
the executives at Twitter making these
choices on what to do with this type of
content so there's the incompetence of
certain incompetence system or a
malfunction or a weak system is part of
it but there's the the people aspect is
interesting because this is seems to
still be somewhat debatable as to
whether they are ideologically Ben and
you've shown data that actually
overwhelmingly they are of one political
uh thought or philosophy
um uh and I'm I I want to understand
their motivation why why are they making
certain decisions and another aspect
which is probably linked is is is the
how they were working with government on
this and and uh how would you sort of
describe or how would you explain what
was going on there so one of the things
that I found was
um an email from an executive named
Lauren Culbertson where she described
what had happened and this happened with
the Trump White House too
um but there was far more information
about the Biden
um white house where they were having
meetings regularly with the social media
platforms and they the Biden White House
made it very clear she characterized
them as being quote very angry that
Twitter had not de-platformed
um a number of users
um who according to the White House were
tweeting false information or misleading
information
so we know that the executive branch of
the government essentially had their
boot on the neck of these people at
Twitter
um and to their credit what I observed
over and over again at Twitter took
almost in every instance were people who
were genuinely struggling and debating
about what to do so the system you
described I think was was flawed but
when the people were having
conversations about this they oftentimes
pushed back against the government these
were these were people who were doing
the best they could I think and they
weren't sure you know under the
directives given to them either by the
you know people at the top of Twitter or
you know indirectly by the government
and I've heard some people say well the
government's just asking I mean that is
an incredibly
um naive position to take about how the
world functions if you run a
multi-billion dollar company and you
have people from the White House you
know winking at you and saying we sure
would like you to do this yeah you know
but we're just asking I mean these are
people who are you know in charge of
regulating your particular company in
your industry that that matters when
they're quote asking you to do something
on your platform it's it's I can sort of
see when it comes to the issue of covid
how this it was so distressing for
everyone wherever whatever you sort of
thought about it where those are
difficult decisions to make but there
were also political decisions made and
and Barry showed that the suppression of
conservative voices the suppression of
the hunter Biden laptop removing Trump
from Twitter after John 6 there was uh
overwhelmingly anti-conservative uh
suppression of speech going on on a
Twitter which is it's harder to sort of
be sympathetic to that because it seems
so against American values so against
the First Amendment and Bill of Rights
so do you think that still applies that
sort of you seem almost empathetic with
the the people uh I'm empathetic with a
lot of the people who worked there who
maybe this wasn't their choice I have
I'm even you know and I'm sympathetic
toward even the executives who decided
to follow along with what the White
House is telling you
um
I have less sympathy toward the
government who was you know kind of
leaning on them for this and I have less
sympathy toward the idea that
you know you don't no one wants to be on
a social media platform where anything
goes where it's just this like Cesspool
of like you know um you know violence
and porn and you know
um so there is some sort of gray area
between well how do we regulate this
environment my personal take on it is
you need to lean toward latitude toward
um allowing as much as possible
including things that may be incorrect
that's far better it's sort of like a
rough analogy would be you know the the
legal system in America you know with um
uh you're considered you know uh not
guilty you know and you know and rather
than they don't say innocent they say
not guilty that there's this burden of
proof I'd much rather err on the side of
of allowing more things because it's
better to have sunlight than it is to
have Darkness it is better to have and
let the best ideas win out
um and again that doesn't mean that
completely outlandish crazy easy stuff
should be allowed on there and I don't
know where the line should be drawn but
what I do know is from what I observed
and what I wrote about is that having
doctors quote from studies from
peer-reviewed journals having their
tweets nevertheless taken down having
their accounts suspended is a horrible
totally unacceptable situation and
ultimately and I and this is you know
winding its way through the courts right
now what some lawyers argue is that this
was essentially a violation of First
Amendment rights by proxy yes the
government didn't go to someone's house
and take their MacBook and smash it over
their knee but by leaning on the
platforms by telling them what they
wanted what type of content they thought
was unacceptable by proxy they
essentially were infringing on their
first amendment rights that's at least
the legal argument I don't know you know
how that will work out in the courts but
I think certainly from a kind of um in
the spirit of that law even if it not
the letter of the law that's what me
seems to be the case with regards to the
court and and it as as you suggested
it's the house oversight and
accountability committee that's going to
what is the significance of that is is
the the the the Republicans have the
majority in in congress not in the
Senate so even if let's say they push
this through is it just going to end as
soon as it hits the Senate what what
does it does it really matter so it's
interesting I mean I think it matters
it's good that this at least that some
people are being held accountable or at
least publicly
um held accountable insofar as this is
being discussed publicly in in the you
know seat of government
um
I think ultimately you're right I mean
unless there is a real bipartisan desire
for this
um I think there's which there isn't
which there is not it's still a joke
really even so it's not just amongst the
Democrats a handful of
um of some infectious disease doctors
epidemiologists
um there's an infectious disease person
I know at um at niaid that's voucher's
old agency a handful of these people
um reached out to me and they were
saying we really want there to be a
covid-19 commission and the way there
was like a 911 Commission that happened
this notion of like a bipartisan sort of
thing and I said you and I said guys I
gotta tell you
um even if there is more media coverage
of this idea unless the politicians
really want to do it you know I don't
think it's going to happen and number
one number one number two
I think even if there is a commission
the same dynamics that led to all the
problems in the pandemic I suspect will
also plague the commission the same you
know what we call like zero coveted
people the same kind of wrong thinking
people who had bad ideas during the
pandemic they're going to be consulted
again for the commission so I I have a
lot of
um pessimism about a whether that'll
even happen or B even if it does I don't
know there's a lot of people who want
some sort of Reckoning to happen I don't
think that's going to happen ever I
think all we can do is or at least when
I say I guess I'm speaking for myself is
to continue to try to write about what I
investigate what I observe to be true
and bring that to as many people as I
can and
um I I don't think there will be some
sort of big Reckoning David as an
American does that not concern you that
there's been such breaches against the
First Amendment and that there won't you
just don't think there'll be a reckoning
and what does that mean for the future
of this country I mean you know I I
think I've just become I was I've always
been cynical but I think now it's just
I I think there are unfortunately limits
to I think a lot of these things sound
good in theory but in practice and let's
be honest the people on the right they
they happen I happen to align with them
about a lot of the the what happened
during the pandemic but I don't align
with them on a variety of other issues
um and I don't think that they're you
know the heroes necessarily in this
either
um I don't want to take away from them
what having largely what I believe to be
the correct view on a lot of the
policies so I'm not saying saying that
those weren't sincerely held but I think
that you know this is complicated stuff
yeah although I was a political science
major in college nevertheless this is
you know beyond my
um ability to really
understand or talk about about what's
going to happen we have a what seems to
be you know this is a total banal you
know kind of cliche at this point we
have a broken system there are two
parties
um they both people are tribal and you
know you're on a team or the B team I
had to talk with um Andrew Yang about
this a guy who is you know pretty
prominent um Democratic yeah but he was
I but he but he believes in this kind of
third-party idea and for whatever
complex mix of reasons that never really
has caught on in America but I think
this sort of binary system
um creates this you know a series of bad
incentives the type of people who become
senators and Congress people let alone a
president
those type of people tend to you know
want to be in power otherwise you
wouldn't you don't get there by accident
you get there because there's something
in your personality that thinks yeah
yeah I should be in charge you know it's
a personality type and so those type of
people I think are going to be highly
incentivized to do what's going to work
best for them and within their tribe so
you have this system I think it's just
what we're going to be left with but you
know all I can do as a writer and a
thinker is to try to
create what I hope is a document of what
happened and create a document of the
evidence and so I mean that's what I'm
doing with the book that I'm working on
now what's the name of the book so the
book is called an abundance of caution
and you know that was a phrase that was
used all the time in the beginning of
the panda out of an abundance of caution
we're closing schools out of an
abundance of caution we're going to do
what they called a deep cleaning I never
got it got a clear uh definition of what
a deep cleaning is versus regular
cleaning but everything was out of an
abundance of caution but but the
question is caution toward what and it
was cautioned toward
a virus but not cautionary toward all
these other things and this is what
Martin and Jay you know have talked
about all along is that there are harms
that happen and importantly and this is
the important part for for liberals to
understand the harms were
disproportionate to poor people and to
black people and to other people who
were not in the same socioeconomic
environment as people in the laptop
class yes you can call them so that's
the painful irony of this to me is that
these policies
disproportionately harmed the people
that ostensibly at least progressives
and liberals care about helping the most
if I can bring you back just one last
time to the please San Francisco
supposedly there's a lot that hasn't
been made public
can you give us any tidbits any any
anything that really surprised you or
shocked you that hasn't that we don't
know about that the the presumably
there's just tons more to to be
investigated so I was there for three
days and it was very hard to do the
searching that I was doing and I was
there Michael schellenberger and Lee and
Leighton they helped me at times we were
all helping each other but I was like
guys I I need help so we were given
dumps of 5 000 emails you know I had a
clip and you and that requires how did
you get through that I mean reading a
lot you know I'm just seeing her quickly
scrolling through doing word searches
like trying to to Wade with your
engineer sat next to you yeah so the
engineer was searching
um he performed searches on people's
accounts and then made a different
system where if we wanted to see slack
Channel Communications or emails that
was done on a separate special laptop
that they did the searches outside the
room we would have to email like them
send them this is what we want they
would perform the search and then they'd
bring in the laptop with it was it was
like a crazy system
um so it was
sorry this is a long answer to your
question which is
what I found is what I was able to find
within the amount of time I was there
um I don't know what else is there so I
there's nothing that I've seen I wish I
had like a great secret there's nothing
I've seen that's like incredible that
that I was told to withhold as a matter
of fact I just want to State very
clearly and publicly I had zero
um constraints placed on me Elon Musk
did not pick me he didn't tap me on the
shoulder so when people were like yeah
Elon Musk that's not true
um he had given access to Barry Weiss
and Barry Weiss asked me to come out
um the only stipulation there's no NDA
there's nothing the only stipulation was
you need to publish on Twitter first
whatever you find but other than that
there was no limitations placed on what
we could look for or what we could
publish
um so uh well on that note on that um
fascinating conversation I I guess
um I listeners will want to know how
they can follow you uh where they can
read your work and um uh keep it stay
tuned with the the world of David's Vibe
yes yes so um I have a website
davidswag.com I'm on sub stack
um so I'm easy to find there under my
name there and um and I'm still writing
for a variety of places my own sub stack
and and most importantly the book that
I'm working on so it's a very people
it's funny for a
years now I keep getting on and thank
God for my editor who's allowing me to
blow by all of my deadlines but what I'm
trying to create as I said before is
this sort of historical document
um that this thing that's going to
actually describe maybe in a decade from
now someone will look back and be like
Oh okay that's that's what was going on
um and I think the element of because
it's just tying into with you saying
where can people find you
um is how the media in it was so
influential
um in this whole environment that
happened and to me as someone part of
the media yet also I view myself as an
outsider as well
um I'm I've occupied this strange space
of the inside or Outsider where I've
been writing for places like the
Atlantic or the New York Times and New
York Magazine
um but yet writing from an angle that
was largely
um not seen I think from a lot of those
Publications so um
I think there's this this larger story
about how the media affects us as a
society and both reflects what's
happening but also of course you know
projects um and influences what happens
so all that stuff gets bundled together
um in a way that's perpetually
frustrating but also fascinating it
sounds very important book and actually
continues to look up just how the
Twitter files were covered by the
mainstream media if they were covered
it's the same the same thing continued I
hope that you also write a book about
your experiences
um there I will say that the Twitter the
last I checked my thread on Twitter had
more than 60 million views and to my
knowledge it was completely ignored by
any mainstream news outlet and even if
the editors and writers there think that
the information what they called was the
nothing Burger the storm this is an
important or not really showing which I
I would vehemently disagree with even if
you think it's not important the fact
that this
investigative reporting was viewed by 60
million people yeah means that that in
and of itself it has some newsworthiness
what does that tell us that it was
completely ignored remarkable right yeah
exactly well David thank you so much for
speaking with me thank you this is
terrific
[Music]
thank you